we would make cakes and uh one one
group decided they did one team they
decided they're not even gonna try
so they put dog [ __ ] in their cake
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i am
sorry laughing i am your host
your roast coming queen a
girl who would wear one pink converse
and one black converse with one pink
sock and one black sock on the opposite
foot and act like i don't know that
meant something
elise morales and with us today
we have such a funny friend we're
already laughing
you've seen her on search party broad
city and shrill she's a writer
on joe para talks with you but before
all of that she was a graduate
of clayton high school it's joe
firestone
that is my exact bio thank you so much
thank you
uh and hello to your little fiance who
popped in
during the intro just his little face
it's pretty amazing he knows
that this podcast has a video component
he did it on purpose
okay so what um this is like the first
question i always ask everyone
what like flavor of high school
was clayton high school like what
private
public uh sports focused
theater focused hippie-ish
conservative et cetera well it was in
missouri and it's a public school
okay um so i don't uh but i
i don't i wasn't i definitely wasn't the
only jewish person
there okay i don't know in missouri
though you know
they're just uh but i think
that sports were a pretty big deal they
really liked sports
i didn't really know much about that but
they they were sports were big
and um let's see what else oh they you
know
at some point they um yeah the the
you know the lunch was pretty standard
you know
your chicken sandwiches hot cheese do
you have a favorite
do you remember what your like go-to
cafeteria meal would be
or like the one you would be the most
excited to receive
yeah i i really ate a lot throughout the
day i
i had a mid-morning breakfast i had a
breakfast before school and then a
mid-morning breakfast
of a bagel with strawberry cream cheese
and then
i had a chicken sandwich for lunch and
i would try to get another snack at some
point
it was really bread focused so you were
yeah you were staying
fueled i really tried to be cool
freshman year and then i gave up
and even freshman year i was giving up
but i remember this was a turning point
i remember i was nobody was talking to
me at the lunch table
and i go i go oh who's gonna give me
five dollars to eat this wasabi
someone had wasabi and they were like no
no and i was like who's gonna give i'll
eat the whole thing for five dollars
who thinks it's avocado and they were
like
and nobody was listening to me and i was
like i'm gonna do it
and then i ate it and it hurt so bad and
nobody
looked at me and it was i was like i
gotta get i gotta go back to
some different friends just like okay
well i guess i'm going to the nurse
[Laughter]
cool we had a kitty wasabi at my lunch
table but it was in elementary school i
think the trick
i think that the trick might be for a
younger girl
definitely as a younger younger group
joke um
yeah i definitely turned i turned very
red and i remember one kid was like why
are you so red
that was yeah so was most of your
in your early high school years when you
were your freshman year when you're like
trying to be cool
where was most of the plan revolving
around
like like food pranks or what was that
yeah food pranks were pretty big
uh yeah that was pretty big for me um
what were the other parts of your
strategy
uh one time i i was really into them
like
whenever there was a new kid i got a
crush on them
because i thought oh they don't know me
oh they don't
this is the perfect chance and so there
was a new kid
and he had really big teeth and it was
so
cute and then um i'm right i
uh was gonna see him at the dance and
i called him before and i go oh blake
i look so different now and i'd
straighten my hair
and then he he was like when we got to
the dance he
was like you don't look that different
but you got the number you got his
number well there was there was a buzz
book you know
oh well that's true
yeah i forgot that like in elementor and
like in middle school and stuff
you would just get everyone's number and
you could call it
you could call anyone's number talk to
anyone's parents yeah it's a pretty big
deal
i remember like the rush of getting
someone's screen
name or like giving like exchanging sn's
on the bus i feel like was always a
thing
or like once i got
if you got someone you had a crushes on
screen name that kind of took things to
a new level
yeah i bet so i yeah i was pretty i
really begged my dad for aol but he
didn't
get it so did you not you were you off
all the like aim none of that stuff i
i aim but i i wasn't really connected i
was it got it too late and then
i ended up getting a uh hotmail email
address
um later on that i i was pretty active
on craigslist but
before then i was yeah i was kind of not
super kicked into the computer
was was aim because i'm like
i'm trying to place when aim like
came into like the high schoolers
world i guess and i'm wondering if maybe
just like the couple years between us
was everyone else using aim and you were
just off it or was it like not a
necessary part
this is hard to answer it's hard to come
to terms with so
i do think that probably a lot of people
were using it
i think that i'm sorry i realized that
that's a painful question for you
i'll ask you no i think that you're
bringing up a really valid point and
yeah yeah i think that probably a lot of
people were
on their chit chatting away
just okay got it okay cool moving on
okay okay i don't think we need to dig
into that anymore
i would i mean i think that uh uh
there's you know there's like a thing
where like
i uh i wish i had i think that i found a
group of friends
ultimately it wasn't so i found a group
of friends ultimately and we were kind
of the group that like
we weren't um
like that it would uh we ended we ended
up having an
a nice sober time you know there was a
okay
uh-huh good kids yeah
kinda yeah a little yeah but i remember
i told
i told my friend i was like um
do you know that we weren't uh cool in
high school
and she goes really but we had so much
fun
and she thought that that equated to
cool and it was so heartwarming and also
like
oh oh honey
no when you're cool it's hell
[Laughter]
it's actually much worse
oh so how did you guys find each other
how did this group
form well i don't know we just started
watching movies every weekend and we'd
get really into this thing where
we'd uh you know get our faces wet and
dip them in big containers of sprinkles
and then
take turns being the one with the
sprinkles on their face
okay yeah i mean that is fun we put dog
[ __ ] into a cake mix i mean we're trying
to do some wild stuff
you know really really wacky stuff
okay so um
where did you put dog [ __ ] into a cake
mix how did that
play out and for what purpose
there would we we would com we would
make cakes
and each try each other's cakes
and uh one one group decided they did
one team they decided they're not even
going to try
so they put dog [ __ ] in their cake
were you on that team no no listen i had
my mom bake my cakes for me
i was like did you eat the cake no no i
knew
i knew in advance there was dog [ __ ] in
there but could anyone eat the cake
yes yes for sure for sure
you know there's doing some wacky stuff
you know
i don't think we were morally uh
upstanding or good
you know that's what i'm saying i feel
like
putting dog [ __ ] in a cake sober
is such an interesting yeah for me i
would
because i remember there was some fecal
antics in my high school group but they
involved
there's alcohol involved yeah i think
that would make a lot more sense for
sure
a lot of the stuff that we were doing i
think that could could really
be knocked out of the park if with just
a couple of beers or four locals what
have you but
this was just um yeah sober shenanigans
i do feel like though when you were like
in high school and when you're younger
you could like you could get yourself so
hyped up that almost you were
kind of in a high a high state like i
feel like me and my friends would like
run around
and just like scream and like jump on
stuff
yeah yeah that was really big jumping
around screaming and stuff for sure
i yeah i remember that was uh a big deal
i had a
a my brother i had his old car and
it was my mom's old car that my brother
got and he took them it was a minivan
that he took the middle seat out of
so that he uh he could have
you know intimacy in the back
and right but then i i wasn't strong
enough to put the
middle seat back in when i got the car
so i just had this like weird kind of
limo
uh mini van situation going on
no we just we just had a it was a
five-seater minivan you know with a lot
of space in the middle so
um yeah that a lot of you know we had
some nice
times in there you know driving around
did you drive the minivan to school
yeah i picked up i would drive and pick
up freshmen and
drive to school you know in a safe way
you know a safe way was it like
organized by the parents where they were
like
joe's such a nice girl she's got she's
got this minivan
her friends did put [ __ ] in a cake but
she wasn't on that team
and she she didn't really have anything
to do with it so
we need her to be picking up the
youngins i think so
i think i don't even know how i got
connected with these people but i was
yeah i was picking them up every day
yep i uh i had a
pt cruiser wow
really um you know
it was tough it was it was tough going
uh
my parents my parents rented a pt
cruiser
once when they were like
on vacation and they liked it and it
just so happened to correspond with my
16th birthday
and me getting my license and so the
next thing i knew like
i had a pg cruiser and i was just like
okay
cool um wow
that rocks uh i did use it
to pull my i would say most successful
scam which is that i parked as a parent
in parent parking every day because to
have your own parking spot
was like really expensive and i didn't
have that kind of money i worked at
subway like i don't have that
you were a sandwich artist i was a
sandwich artist
i was i was like so eager to get a job
and have money
and uh i applied everywhere and i
remember i had to take like a
psychological test to work at the
grocery store
and i failed it i was so bummed i failed
the psychological test
um that literally you saying that
reminds me that i failed a psychological
test to work at the hallmark
store
i was like i mean this is a piece of
cake i could definitely work at the
hallmark store
no
wasn't it like a test to see if you
wouldn't steal or if you really
trust oh my gosh it was it was so
embarrassing too like i just remember
they kept asking the same question over
and over again and i kept being like
well why would i
answer this the same way but i think
that's what you're supposed to be doing
you know what it was i it was the same
thing for me i think that they try to
determine if you're a liar
by changing the way that they ask the
question but i'm like
but changing the way you ask a question
always changes people's answers
it's the basis of polling it's the basis
of following
nate silver but i i i yeah i think
i i guess i just remembered this now so
yeah ninth grade
i wasn't i was babysitting but then
i had a little bit you know one of those
uh that was a real uh what you'd call a
suicidal year
you know a real uh try trying to end it
and then after that i got on this
medicine
that um the major side effect was
uh that it was like almost no side
effects except for that your
tongue would move uncontrollably oh
god and so i was having i was really
well adjusted then but my tongue was
always like
all day long and i was like i don't
think it's
i don't notice the side effects but um
did okay so was the medication otherwise
helpful
yeah yeah for sure for sure
just uncontrollable tongue movements
did you ever get called out was anyone
ever like joe you've always got like
something going on
i think i was just so weird at that
point there was
so i was always i was all i was that one
always cracking her back
you know and um yeah um
i also so my freshman year i was also
very very depressed and like my grades
went to [ __ ]
and i like i i was so
like confused about
what was going on because it was kind of
like the first time i had this like wave
of like adult
feeling was this like something you've
been going
through from prior in middle school or
did it just was it kind of all part of
the like upheaval of getting into high
school and
i think i i just was kind of out of my
league also like
maybe i mean i don't think this has
anything to do with it but so
i the freshman year yeah
right right away freshman year was 9 11
and it was like this like weird scary
time and then
i remember also i just uh i just i
couldn't really
um handle uh change so much so
i a lot of times back to the buzz book
what i would do and i'm glad i've i've
cut this habit is uh
i would think about throughout the day
everyone that i might have wronged
and then after school i would go home
and get out the buzz book
and call them and leave messages on
their
family message machines being like this
is joanna firestone i'm so sorry for
what i did to you today
yeah it did so did people
call you back no no
i think this is you know i'm realizing
as i'm telling you this this is a
this is a this was a dark time but in a
way well it's
i mean first of all it's like i'm
touched by what you're doing like
there's
it's it's very sweet and like i can see
this like
little girl being like oh my god i blew
it all day and like i just gotta
like get back to these people and like
we
we can figure this all out but
i gotta like did people respond what did
people
respond to these what are you talking
about
what's what are you what is happening
and so i think that i just
you know i think i needed to um you know
i think i needed to uh get
i think it was a time of change i needed
to get some
some close friendships which i did and
and that
really did help quite a bit so
it was like a combination of that and
getting on
medication and stuff do you feel like we
were in a different place by like
sophomore
year because i for me my freshman year
was like
very very bad and then once i
kind of started to be like okay i live
here now i have to be in this building
all the time i kind of get how it works
things slowly got a little bit better
yeah i think so i think that um i think
it
yeah it got a little bit easier i got a
rolly backpack
um so you know they could hear me coming
no matter where i was
and that was pretty exciting and uh yeah
i think it was
it did that definitely got a little
easier for sure
okay so were you involved
did you have like extracurriculars that
you did
or what was your what was what was
teen joe's uh academic plate
like oh man i had a lot of activities
i was really interested in recycling
club
oh okay that's where you go around with
the trash can dump in all the papers
from the classrooms after school oh so
you're the recycling club just
just takes out the church
well that's good hey a lot of paper in
that school
yeah so that that was a big deal that
was a big deal for me
um and besides recycling club i was also
really into theater i really liked okay
uh-huh great i was gonna be like are we
performing
at all so what um what plays
did you do what plays did we do
i think we did we did les miserables oh
my god
were you in it i was in it yeah who were
you
i played that little boy gavroche
oh i would see you as god roche now
thank you
thank you thank you so much
someone should really do that
oh that's so fun if my school had ever
approached doing les mis
i would have wanted to be gabrosh i
think really i mean there really are
some better parts in there but i
i'm glad that you watched i don't know
are you
like where's your singing and dancing
ability
it's low can't sing and i can't dance
which is unfortunate those are the
others i love the most
i if i like if a genie appeared to me
and was like i can make you amazing at
like anything i would not
pick like comedy at all i would be like
singing and dancing
but you can dance i've seen you dance
you can dance
i it takes a really long time for me to
learn a dance
like what you saw was the results there
was a lot
to make that happen and i also made up
the dance so like
in those conditions yeah i can dance
it does it does seem like such an
amazing skill like
i oh man i watched this documentary the
other day called every little step and
it was following all these people
auditioning for the chorus line on
broadway the revival
they're so talented everyone's so
talented
and not most of them aren't getting it
yeah
it's seeing a really good dancer like
really does it for me
oh my god we did we did
famously because i bring it up on every
episode of the podcast we did wizard of
oz and there's a really big dance in
wizard of oz that i did not have to
participate in
it was cut from the film but
it's called the jitterbug dance and it's
this huge
thing and there was like one popular
girl in our theater
like in our entire theater program um
who was like on the dance team which was
the most popular thing that you could be
at my high school on the dance team and
she got all the dance team girls to be
in the jitterbug dance so the jitterbug
dance
that's like amazing and also sexy
wow who what characters are supposed to
be doing is it the monkeys or is it the
um the mains the dorsey
all of them i believe what happens is
the wicked witch infects
them with something that makes them do a
crazy dance and they can't stop dancing
and then there's also all these
jitterbugs that are also dancing
interesting you know my dog was in
wizard of oz
was toto yeah oh my god
how do you get that gig yeah it was
pretty big so
uh yeah it was a community theater
production of wizard of oz oh that's
awesome
both my dog and my dad tried out and my
dog got departed and my dad
didn't get in he was pretty pissed and
kind of jealous of my dog the whole
summer
oh my god he wouldn't even take him to
rehearsals that does suck
to have to take like when you don't get
in the pl
like when you don't get in the play when
you're in high school you don't have to
then take your friend to rehearsal
so you can't be competing with people in
your own home yeah
exactly that's that's the biggest
takeaway from all this
yeah um okay so you were gavroche in les
mis
what other like did you one of their
like shows or big performances do you
remember
well um i got i have two i had two
boyfriends
that was really big at the same time
no different times okay okay
yeah and were they met through the
theater
they were theater boyfriends they were
not not one of them was not
oh one of them one of them gave me such
a big
corsage for the dance that
everybody called me the prized pig
oh my god
the prize pig joe
okay
were you how did did you just let
everybody call you the prized pig
or were you like guys no
[Laughter]
it's kind of at that point you kind of
just have to embrace embrace that you're
the prized pig
um yeah you're right the more you push
against it
the harder it's gonna stick yeah yeah
that's what i figured just kind of
embrace it and so
yeah that's uh that's kind of like what
um
yeah well so so i have no recollection
of this
but um this this woman girl this girl at
the time uh she made a documentary
for her like newspaper class or
something
about this production of a theater of a
play that and we were all in it
and um in the production in the
in the in the production i remember
thinking like
oh it's uh like i'm like
okay so there were it was a it was a
play called ash girl
and it was basically cinderella mixed
with the seven deadly sins
okay was this student written no
okay no believe it or not it's a
working writer so so um
so i was like uh there's seven deadly
sins right
and um like
i was hoping for lust
i thought that would be a nice role for
me okay
i thought it's sexy it's fun it was my
senior year i thought
i can i can ask for this and how's the
year to be sexy and fun
exactly if it's not then when
it's college yeah right come on that's
that's that's a real bad
i'm hitting the books okay college i'm
studying
i'm hitting the books in high school i'm
going for looks right that's what they
say
so then i uh i uh looked at the cast
list
after begging for weeks to be lust and i
got
a character called glutton toad okay and
this was a toad
character that ate the whole time and i
was so pissed and
so angry the whole time with this stupid
part
and then i remember um in the
documentary i was like
such a brat i was really embarrassed by
this footage because i was just like
yeah sometimes miss ryan she's just like
really not a nice woman talking about
this drama teacher that
clearly was trying so desperately to
help this bunch of losers
and i was so terrible i and i have no
recollection of it until
you talk [ __ ] in the dark
you you went full like reality tv that
fast
yeah another documentary which i
recommend
is this i forget what it's called but
it's basically uh
they track these like three high school
productions
and then they compete in like i think
they're called the danny's or the
the tommies is it the cappies
maybe the cappies but the copies were
really really big
where i'm from and the cappies are a big
deal
it could be that but it was and it was
like you just see all these
like little brats like so mean to each
other
and like clearly they all hate each
other they're so competitive and it's
it made me um very nostalgic
were you that deep into your theater
world of like theater kid stuff because
i was
very much that deep in i well i wasn't
talented
and i think that that's a big thing that
you need to be to have
power in that world so i didn't really
have that but i did
i did uh find a little door
and this little door if you snuck in
you went under the stage and found all
the old desks
like from the 50s and so
i found out about that and that was my
power so i would bring people back
underclassmen and have them sign their
names
wow how did you find it
somebody showed me so it was passed down
someone is goes in every year to kind of
be the person
who shows everyone where the defense
yeah it's usually not the most talented
person but someone with enthusiasm
someone with time on their hands to
show other people
they don't need to be on stage during
rehearsals so they can be showing
everybody where the little desks are
um i always felt like i always like
wanted
when i was in high school i like wanted
to find something like that especially
in the theater like whenever i would
like go
up to where the lights were and stuff
and like the kids who were in theater
tech who were always
fingering each other up there and doing
sexual stuff
up there and were like way more sexual
than the actual actors
they would like show me their little
sexy place up there and i'd be like wow
that's really [ __ ] cool
oh i remember it just speaking of
okay so uh just so you know i went to
high school with a lot of future members
of nexium
okay wow okay just kind of making it
topical i want you to know that
okay are they in the dock
you went to you went to high school with
people who are in
the dock
okay well will you tell me offline who
the boy is
for sure that's okay great i mean
okay could you but this is just to say
so one of them so we had this cast party
okay
and um one of their uh girlfriends at
the time
she was like she she was like come here
do you want to know what [ __ ] tastes like
and i was like
yeah and then she put salt in seven up
and had me drink it
did it taste like cup like now
exactly spot on
are you serious the last time i i was
slurping up come
i thought what is this seven up with
salt in it
that's that is the most like
cast party thing
i can imagine oh my god
that's such a high school moment and
trick
and i also love that you said yeah
i was down you know i was really i was
down
i feel like young joe does have a really
horny energy
like you're going out in a way that
high schoolers with rolling backpacks
don't usually have
because thank you
you openly went for the role of lust
like you told your teacher you wanted it
yeah yeah i did i did for sure
uh-huh and you wanted to know what [ __ ]
tastes like
uh-huh you got two boyfriends yeah
so it seems like romantically like
you're doing all right how long were the
two boyfriends
like when were they a year and i don't
i don't remember this but apparently
there is one story where
um i was trying to give a hj to one of
my boyfriends in
in his um in his mom's uh camry
and uh he has a classic place to give an
hj
and he asked me not to because i i was
it was gonna make a mess
okay so my hands were grabbing for
things and and people were saying no no
so just putting it out there i
would always give my high school
boyfriend hand jobs over his cargo
shorts
and then he would come in his pants
and we would just be like cool okay and
then
kind of continue the day and it's like
no this guy came
he has to go home like
amazing i've got to say that it's pretty
amazing it also seems like
it couldn't have felt really good
because cargo pants have like that
chunky zipper
and like oh yeah really really really
chunky zipper on a cargo short
yeah that's tricky i mean that's really
tricky i think
yeah i remember hearing about some
people that would give they would go
go over the pants during lunch haven't
having the hj's
in the hallway that kind of thing you
know you have to make some
some arrangements but i i remember
hearing about that while eating
you know muffins and chicken salad and
you know
pretty wild stuff
okay do you remember you know it's
a chicken salad it's pretty good
chicken salad is good yeah okay
was it was um did your school serve
chicken salad or was
were you up did you bring lunch from
home no i got went and got it from the
grocery store
oh were you able to like uh leave
campus during lunch yeah yeah go get
chicken salad
yeah i remember one time one time we
went to arby's
i went to arby's at 10 30 in the morning
with this guy named whitey
every high school has one
[Laughter]
and i remember we we i remember thinking
he really takes his time eating arby's
because he was eating it till the end of
lunch hour but i had to eat mine pretty
fast
oh if i'm getting arby's i eat it in two
seconds
[Music]
there's no reason why are we pretending
do you remember any big
rumors or scandals or
happenings of your high school
yeah yeah for sure lay it on us well i
remember when
um when uh
this this girl liz got she did oral i
mean anal sex
that was pretty big that's huge
mm-hmm yeah and this other girl leah she
was able to wear the lowest waisted
pants without showing her butt crack
and that was really really commendable
i like i remember those butts from my
high school too
where i'm like how are you doing that
how is it staying up really low
and uh let's see what else happened oh
um
yeah i um well one time i got
i got into a car accident this was a
really big deal so i got into a car
accident
and i wasn't allowed to have anyone in
my car i was only allowed to have one
person in my car
and so um i but i had you know full
minivan you know that's at least five
seats with the middle seat taking out
and so the three people in the back i
made them um
get out of the car and run home
that joe that's my sister did the exact
same thing when she got in a car
accident
she told her friends scatter and they
all went and
they went into the woods and they ran
away
oh my god that is really oh you know
what another
so did this get around your high school
where people that i was a really bad
driver that i was
i was notoriously bad driver i went down
one way streets the wrong way
i was really bad but in a minivan too
one thing that was i was kind of known
for i guess not me but
my family my dad was a magician
oh okay was he like like did he like
do everyone's birthday party when they
were younger yeah he did a lot of
birthday parties he was
yeah and then he would uh he would do
this thing where he'd call the wizard
and um the wizard would guess your card
over the phone ah and
uh and at that point everyone had come
over had met the wizard
and then finally my senior year we met
the wizard
like
in what capacity wait who is the wizard
i'm so
confused we call the wizard the wizard
would say
here's your cart okay the wizard but
this time he came
he showed up yeah and he was who
um he well we had an uzbekistani
exchange student at one point and so uh
the
it was um yeah this guy
showed up and he had the the robe that
the student gave us
on and um he was
yeah he was uh definitely my dad's
friend
um joe i cannot picture what you are
describing
at all i've talked to people in a while
so i'm sure these stories are really bad
okay so you're dead
okay i'm gonna put to you the what i
picked up from this story
that you told me
so your dad was a known magician
in your town he had a
like bit that he did where he would call
him
he would call the wizard on the phone
and the wizard would guess your card
and then your senior year and
ooze back man showed up pretty
much a man where he was traditionally
steady close
okay a man in tradition who's like
any clothes came to your house and he
was the wizard
and it's hard to see it's hard to see
and this was a big deal at your school
well i guess not at my school i guess
first seven of us
it was pretty big deal and then my dad
said we had to graduate high school in
order to meet the wizard
but then one of my friends didn't
graduate high school so that it just it
just we just had to
get to may did you but your dad still
let you meet the wizard even though your
friend didn't graduate yeah everyone
that's good
yeah yeah and it was just kind of your
dad's friend
yeah okay
okay
great rumor
[Laughter]
all right i think this brings us to the
end of the pod so i'm going okay
and i'm and i'm very interested to hear
your answer to this because i've gotten
gotten an image of a young you know
maybe she's she's not uh 100
sturdy on her feet but she's a she's a
budding sexual
woman she's not afraid to get a
boyfriend
she's got good friends she's involved in
various
activities so if you could talk to
teen joe today what would you tell her
oh my god this is the most emotional
part of encore it is the most emotional
part of encore
what if i started crying right now i it
like it really um
once i watched encore i was like am i
like
really putting a lot on people by asking
them this is an encore
everyone cries fully burst into tears
and some people have given very
emotional answers to the question but
yeah you don't have to cry oh okay
okay i'll try not to but uh i guess i
think that um
i think matt rodgers did cry actually oh
man
it was really sweet i was like i'm gonna
cry
so you can cry and it actually does make
a good moment and vulture did write that
episode up
so just keep that in mind
um okay so i think that i i think that i
would reconsider
i think i was like felt like a pretty
big
loser and uh that that is understandable
because i was
in the conventional sense of it but i
think i would try to adapt more of what
my
friend was trying to say or it's like if
you're having a good time it really
that means you're cool yes
even though i'd be like shut up that's
not true but
i think that is basically it
yeah i really do feel like your friend
got at
the heart of something which is like if
you
get out of this of course sort of insane
institution that we've created for you
to go through at the most
uh emotionally volatile time of your
life if you get out of that with some
friends and good memories like
you nailed it yeah yeah i think so
and i'm still friends with like almost
all of my friends
that's why we're all so old
it is crazy to be old with your friends
now
yeah like to i
like i i really someone that i from my
past
became like a local politician and was
disgraced and i'm like
i can't believe i am old enough to know
a disgraced politician
wow like i'm so that's so crazy
that i'm in i'm in the age range to
even rubbed elbows with
a disgraced politician
i argued with this person on facebook
oh wow i know i know and now
they finally got what's coming to them
all right i think that this brings us to
the end uh joe
it was so great to have you on the
podium it's great to talk to you too and
just to see ya
for everyone everyone else at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
[Music]
podcasts
you